Thank you.
Hey, Poulter.
I've never hosted a space yet where nobody showed up, but today's space is about like karma
and consequences and such.
So I thought that perhaps this would be the one where no one would come out.
There you go.
Let the record show one person did show up.
They didn't care for the topic, but they did come by.
So in a sense, my streak continues.
That hasn't been said, I will be out of here in 10 minutes if no one comes by and stays.
And I'll be in 10 minutes if no one comes by and I'll be in 10 minutes if no one comes by and I'll be in 10 minutes if no one comes by and I'll be in 10 minutes if no one comes by and I'll be in 10 minutes if no one comes by and I'll be in 10 minutes if no one comes by and I'll be in 10 minutes if no one comes by and I'll be in 10 minutes if no one comes by and I'll be in 10 minutes if no one comes by and then I'll be in 10 minutes if no one comes by and I'll be in 10 minutes if no one comes by and I'll be in 10 minutes.
Thank you.
Hey, Ryan, I was actually just about to take off, dude, because this is the first space I've ever posted that no one's shown up for.
Well, but now you showed up.
So thank you.
I don't know if, uh, I don't know if, uh, Tarmic Deep Impact is really your, your speed, but I appreciate the support.
Let me see here, dude.
Uh, let me see here.
Hold on.
I should let me.
Here you go.
Uh, add speakers.
Uh, let me see here.
Hold on.
I should let me.
Here you go.
Uh, add speakers.
Uh, yeah.
Fuck dude.
I am sucking wind today.
Nope.
Good.
Oh, one request to speak.
Ah, you figured it out.
Better than I did.
Yeah.
I requested.
Sometimes X hates me too.
What's going on, man?
All right.
Can you hear me?
I can hear you.
How you doing, man?
Thanks for stopping by.
I'm not sure if you'll be able to because I'm in the car, but I saw you live and I wanted
to pop in and nobody was here.
So, oh yeah, no, this is the first one.
Hey Lou, what's up?
Oh, I see someone showed up.
I almost had a snow day.
Yeah.
No, I, um, I've actually been on a good run.
I've been, I've done like 30 of these.
Hey, Lou's here.
Yeah.
Lou's awesome.
Lou JT is, is a scrambling for something right now.
Um, I'm sure he will be back momentarily.
Oh, I'm here.
You can't hear me, Ryan.
I'm here, dude.
Why you can't hear me?
What is going on, man?
Can you hear me now?
What is happening?
Lou, can you hear me?
Can you give me a, can you send me a sign if you can hear me, dude?
JT, I got you now.
Okay.
Good.
I apologize for the audio quality in advance.
If you didn't hear that I'm in the car.
So, um, no, no, I did hear it.
You know, uh, X, uh, X has it in for me.
Uh, for whatever reason, my spaces always have problems, which is fine.
Um, and look at this, Jack, the last floor scholar is here.
Jack showed up to help too, huh?
No, thank you.
Uh, Jack, it's really cool.
Uh, no, it's good of you guys to show up.
It's very, uh, it's very supporting.
I, I, I appreciate it.
You know, like I said, I've done about 30 of these and I've always had people show up.
And, uh, this time I thought I was going to have a snow day.
I don't let it get to me.
Um, yeah, you know, I would like to do more stuff about gaming, but honestly, I don't
have any gaming, um, followers.
So we're very few.
That's all right.
What is karmic deep impact?
Oh, karmic deep impact.
Well, uh, we were doing a series of, um, spaces on the upcoming, uh, the upcoming astrological
alignment in, uh, in February.
There's a longterm once in 6,400 year astrological alignment, uh, that's coming up on February 20th.
That has about a three year window, a three year orb.
And, um, it's very serious.
Uh, it's very serious alignment.
And, um, part of that, uh, part of that series of events is, uh, what I would turn karmic
deep impact.
Okay.
So as someone that just casually, and I'm going to be honest, 90% of deep astrology
lore that I learned is from you.
So as, as someone incredibly on the periphery, what can you tell a Taurus that this is going
to do for him?
Well, as a, as a, well, okay.
So your chart is different because, um, it, what it does for you is based on houses and
not on signs.
So I need your birth time and I wouldn't be able to do it on air right now.
Cause I need to get on the computer and, and I'm not multitasking.
Right.
But what it means for everybody is that, um, well, look at the world around us.
So the events of the world around us right now are things that some people are still having
trouble sort of coming to grips with, but we were talking about them years ago because
it's, it's represented in the sky.
And the upcoming event, right.
When, when Neptune and Saturn return into Aries, uh, that's when things will begin to
shift in a way that we really, you know, we as a society really don't want them to shift
in, but you know, the point of this, uh, karmic deep impact is to explain that it's on a personal
level on a collective level.
It's, it's a karmic transition.
It is, uh, the consequences of our past actions as opposed to just something that's randomly happening
beyond our control.
So Aries is the sign of war.
Right.
Um, right.
Yeah.
And so Saturn and Neptune, uh, entering Aries and then conjuncting is, um, are serious consequences,
um, for, uh, because of where it is pretty much everyone, pretty much global civilization
related to war.
Right.
So we would look at, if someone asked a few years ago, Hey, when is the war really going
to kick off?
Uh, we would have said, um, either in February and, uh, the, the following spring of, uh, 2026
or in the summer of 2026, when Uranus returns Gemini.
And the reason that that would also be a factor is that, um, Gemini is the sign of division.
So when Uranus enters Gemini, that's when you see the world sort of square off into two camps.
These are both, um, both, uh, Neptune and Aries and Gemini in, uh, no, sorry.
Uranus and Gemini are, um, events that have occurred whenever the U S isn't war.
So, uh, uh, civil war, world war two, uh, revolutionary war.
Right.
So as an individual, there's not much that I can do to mitigate it other than to be aware.
Well, so that's what happens with everyone, but it will also occur, um, in your chart.
And if you had to chart, we could see where, um, these events would have the most profound
impact on your individual life.
Now it could be that these events kind of get out of control, right?
Like this is a pretty big thing.
And so there's like a spillover effect.
If, uh, if people start shooting at each other on the street, right.
Or if bombs start falling and they're going to fall on everyone.
Um, regardless of what your astrological chart is.
However, the personal impact that you'll have, we can find that.
We can find that in your chart.
Now looking at the people around you, right.
You've no doubt noticed that it's not just, uh, it's not just American society or like the
world or the war, right?
Like everyone seems to be up against it right now.
You see this on X, right?
Don't we see this on X?
I think that that is more than a fair statement, even down to like my young children.
So that's, that's reasonable.
That's very reasonable.
And it's limitation, right?
It's a Neptune is dreams, idealism, delusions.
Saturn is limitation.
And so what we have is, uh, during the period when they're in the, we've been going through
when they're in Pisces, we have sort of this unlimited, um, series of dreams and delusions.
Um, we have the woke stuff, right.
That you like to talk about.
We have the woke stuff, which was sort of an unlimited series of dreams and delusions.
It was the imagination of certain people sort of getting the best of them and them sort
of externalizing it to the world around them.
Right.
They personified that feeling.
Sure.
And on the other side, one might say that there has been a little bit of delusion there
as well about how it might turn out.
Right.
And when we make this transition over the next couple of months, we're going to switch into
the, um, this is hard reality.
And when that happens, that's when people start to get a little, a little aggressive, a little
screwy because they want to fight for what they lost.
But that's not on a, on a like national level.
That's on an individual level as well.
So we find that we're like, if you look at X, you'll see that people's posts are getting
a little crazier.
Everyone's starting to complain about right.
Being throttled, being limited.
And we all feel right.
Right.
We all feel like our reach is being limited and it may be in that all of our reach is being
limited.
And, and it may be that that's something that's happening across the board.
Now I, I, you're not, you know, I have, um, some medical issues, some disability issues
because I w I was in an accident some years ago.
And, uh, you know, I have lingering issues because of it.
Well, right now, um, you know, even if I happen to agree with like, some of the things are
happening, there's, uh, some limitations coming in the, um, you know, in the medical care.
Right.
So when I go to see the doctor, now they want a $50, um, co-payment for, I feel that because
2026 rolled around and, um, no surprise.
I had seen a bunch, a ton of specialists.
Right.
And we went from 35 to 50 bucks too.
So I'm right there with you.
And the thing is that we're going to see this in every, um, in every area of life, but each
individual is going to have an area where it's particularly pronounced.
And some people, depending on, um, the details of the natal chart, like it could be really,
really pronounced.
So we're going to see a series of people sort of falling from grace.
Right.
We're going to see, uh, now this is actually interesting enough, this is definitely going
to affect, um, the RPG world.
Uh, but particularly into, um, so what's interesting about the RPG world is, uh, we're going to see
this happen now.
Right.
And I think we are seeing it happen because if you look at, uh, wizards, they just went
out, right.
Didn't they just go out and they sort of made these like inroads.
They tried to make some inroads with a classic gamers.
And they said, well, you know, we're going to bring back dark sun.
Right.
We're going to do right.
Okay.
And then they turned around and they were the craziest people they could get.
Right.
And in fact, any sort of, and I took the bait too, I don't want to turn this into a gaming
thing because that's not what we're here for, but I definitely took the bait because as much
of a on record public pessimist as I can be, I started, started singing, you know, is this
a chance where we can shift back towards not even the classic gamer, but the middle.
So for, for the mainstream gamer, for the every man gamer, and then not a month later, they
brought in a brigade of pronouns.
So yeah, I know exactly what you're talking about.
You're right on the month.
The brigade of pronouns.
They brought in a brigade of pronouns with individuals who also have like lists, right.
That the people get with the lists, the blocking.
Right.
Like as far as extreme as it can get in that direction.
And that's, you see, like, that's the, the karma coming in.
That's that, that karmic deep.
That's the, the results of past actions that cannot be changed at this point.
Right.
So the difference between, excuse me, the difference between fate and destiny is fate are the things
that will happen to you.
And destiny is the inevitable results of your actions.
Right.
Destiny are the dominoes you set in motion.
So what we have right now, we have some faded events.
We also have some destined events.
And in the case of the gaming world, we're seeing some destined events with the, the main
players that we're going to see a strong reaction to that.
Now you say we're not here for gaming, but I'll tell you something.
Uh, gaming is, um, the best possible metaphor you can have for approaching life.
I agree.
It's a microcosm for everything that we do.
Yeah, absolutely.
And as you, as you probably know when gaming, what, what we look at is gaming, the type of
gaming that we do originated, it originated as operative gaming.
So it originated in games that were actually being played in order to predict future events
on battlefields and things like that.
And it's still used for those purposes to this day.
Um, they still have every once in a while, they'll call in a bunch of gamers and have
them game out scenarios in real world political stuff, as opposed to just using computers.
Right.
In fact, I have a friend, I'm not going to dox him, but I have a friend who has a security
clearance and quite legitimately every six to nine months, they play out wargaming scenarios
just to see what would happen.
And they, they, they have, uh, if you can believe this or not, this is something I can
tell you.
Um, the government actually has their own rule set for, for how these games are played, but
they bring in seasoned and, and very, very dedicated, authentic war gamers specifically to do this.
And it's, it's astounding.
The stories that I've heard over a beer that I can't tell you.
And the ones that I can are, are, are very predictable.
You know, a lot of them are tactical scenarios, political scenarios, that sort of thing.
But you are, you are again, right on the money, my friend.
So the three things that I have a strong interest in, and I say, we, the people that I associate
with, right.
So I associate with people who are, you know, strongly interested in astrology, what I would
term metaphysics.
Cause I look at it as it more holistically.
Okay.
I associate with people who are involved in something called, um, coordinate and technical remote
viewing.
Right.
So it's psychics, but I may have heard about this, the government psychic people, right.
There was a thing, there was a, um, a program in the U S and in Russia as well, right.
In the seventies and eighties and nineties.
And it went private in the mid nineties.
And so there are people out there who are for lack of a better term, train psychics.
Right.
But they use a very, I did not know that they effectively went consultant based.
I think I, I assumed that it just evaporated.
No thousands.
As a matter of fact, I, I, I know some of the best I could connect you with them tomorrow.
Um, price cost is a little bit prohibited.
It's not like going to see somebody where you walk into a psychic parlor and you pay 40
bucks.
It's if you have a really intense question and you're willing to pay, um, then you can
get some, I mean, the results are amazing.
These guys are unbelievable.
Um, they work in groups, so they compensate with each other.
You know, if one's having an off day or if the target is one that is someone that doesn't
come easily to one individual, it's groups of four or five.
So they're, yeah, they're usually always, I would say, so they'll say 65%, but I would
say 85%.
I've been following them since the nineties.
They're, they're very active.
So Teresa Caputo, they are not is what you're saying.
Right.
Precisely.
So, right.
So I would add to that operative gaming is the third, right?
So I look at, um, like I love role-playing as for fun for, for past time, but I look at
it as, um, also a model for understanding reality and, um, a way of, I mean, hopefully at some
point I think operative gaming can, can synergize, right?
Isn't that a corporate speak could, could synergize.
I don't know.
I retired in November.
I'm out.
So that's why the $50 copay hurts now.
So it's brutal.
But I think that if they, I think that when working together, right, because what astrology
basically is, is an analog simulation model, and you're familiar with computer simulation
models, like the whole world model in, in the end, I'm sure, you know, the, the whole like computer
simulation concept, but in a real sense, as opposed to the matrix.
Right.
Sure.
And, uh, astrology is an analog simulation model.
That's all it was.
It was developed over 500 years in Babylon and an experiment called ordinary watching.
Like it was a very real experiment.
It lasted for 500 years and they developed this analog simulation model.
Um, the psychic stuff is, um, I think, I think it's, it's how we all experience life.
We just, we have filters.
So I think that, um, we all navigate the world using extrasensory perception, but, um, the people
who are paid to do it are trained to relax their filters.
And so they're able to do it, um, sort of on demand and in a, in a more non-local way,
as opposed to just navigating one individual frame.
Right.
So, um, the thing with, uh, the role-playing is what we believe, um, you know, speaking again,
the royal, we, uh, what we believe is we think that there's some aspect of that to this reality,
that there is some, we call it, instead of calling it a simulation, simulation or a matrix,
we call it a reality overlay.
Um, and that's what the, um, the session material suggests.
And I think that's anecdotally what a lot of us who studied this, the conclusion that we've
sort of come to, um, about reality.
So I think that, um, the development of gaming was inspired by archetypes emanating from the
collective unconscious.
Like, I think it was something that was meant to happen to help us understand the world better.
Like I, I'm a very firm believer in that.
Okay.
Yeah.
No, no.
And that's, that's just cosmically or through the, like you said, um, it's, it wasn't determined.
This is more of a fate thing that this alignment happened.
So the way that, um, the way that it seems to work, um, is you're familiar with, um, on,
to some degree with Jungian stuff, the collective unconscious, right?
Uh, you know, bachelor's level psychology.
Yes.
Right.
So social changes and, um, inventions and things like that, they percolate through the
collective unconscious up into individual and collective consciousness.
So we could like this, some, we could debate on how it works, like what the collective unconscious
really is.
Um, but that's a basic theme that sort of, sort of accepted by most of psychology.
Uh, you, you, you probably heard of like the, well, you, I'm sure you had this cause you're
a really creative dude.
So I'm sure you've had this situation where you've gone to sleep over the problem and you've
woken up the next day with the answer.
Right.
So, but that's what, uh, you know, Tesla and those other inventors, that's what they were doing.
They were to a large degree drawing their inventions from this collective unconscious up into their
individual consciousness.
And in that same sense, it happens to people all at once.
So you'll notice through the course of your life that there are times when everything seems
to change.
Everyone seems.
Sure.
There are those historical golden eras that everybody likes to talk about.
I hate that term, but it's true.
Or, I mean, stuff like a Mandela effect stuff or, um, language will change suddenly.
And everyone will say, well, how can, you know, words, you know, how can even the, the, even
the media transmit words and ideas across the culture in 24 hours, everyone isn't watching
the TV.
Right.
So that would be from our perspective, an emanation from the collective unconscious and an
archetype, a form in the collective unconscious, um, entering our conscious reality.
I mean, the way it tends to happen is, um, our conscious minds, right.
Have a filter that stop us from directly experiencing these ideas.
Like, uh, that's why you have dreams at night, but you, most of us don't have dreams during
the day.
Right.
We have some daydreaming, but we don't have full on dreaming because we have a filter to
stop our mind from doing that.
Right.
And that filter, uh, we use that as a metaphor, but we can say it's, um, brain waves, right.
You have alpha waves, you have beta waves, you have delta waves.
And the combination of those waves changes between when you're asleep and when you're awake.
So there's a very real change in your brain and what you can perceive and experience.
So the physiological firewall is up while we're conscious.
Correct.
Except when we're engaged in creative pursuits, when we're engaged in visual media, when we're
engaged in writing, um, anything gaming, right.
Anything that you have a significant or sufficient level of novelty to entrain your brain.
Right.
Cause you know, when you get into a flow state, your brain waves work differently.
So you're in training your brain and suspending that filter.
And that's why, when you look at that whole Simpsons did it right.
Simpsons said it was going to happen scenario or like, you know, all the times nine 11 supposedly
showed up in popular art music album covers and, and books and that the archetypical planes flying
into buildings.
Right.
Is, uh, information personally up through the collective unconscious that psychics, highly
trained psychics would experience on demand, but for the rest of us that comes out when
we're engaged in creative pursuits and the people who are best at that are best at channeling that
archetypal information into their work.
Boy, it must be unbearable to be able to switch it on.
And if you can switch it off for some of the folks that would be able to, I guess, control
that filter.
You know, creative types are weird and that's why.
Like there's a combination connection between creativity and madness.
It's because you're in that dream state all the time to, to one another.
Yeah.
Whereas other people like they don't have a dreamlike aspect to the life.
But if you're a very creative person, you have periods of your day and definitely, you
know, longer periods during your life where things are very dreamlike.
And that's, that's when you're experiencing the strongest connection to the collective unconscious.
And these ideas are not channeling through you, but they're flowing through you up through
you.
No, it's like a, at least for me, it's like a rhythm, right?
And it is something that you can't prevent.
It's almost, um, if I were to give it a physical analogy, it would be like you are waiting, uh,
across a river or a Creek and you reach the point where the current takes you.
Now, you know, you're still safe, but you can't control where you're going to go.
You, you have basic control over things like direction and resistance, but ultimately you
can't turn it off until you, until it turns itself off.
So I, I, I, I'm sympathetic and understand what you're saying.
And you're a musician, right?
I mean, I think you at least make music with the computer.
I assume that you have.
Yes.
Yeah.
I, I, I haven't, my band broke up decades ago, but we had a fantastic cover.
So when you say like the rhythm though, right, that gives away that it gives it away that
that's how you have the experience.
And I think that those of us who I'm not a musician, but I have the ability sometimes,
and this is gonna make me special.
I'm sure everyone here does, but I can only tell you my own experience.
Right.
So I music certain music, certain types of music.
And you could probably say exactly what it is in the music that does this, but I can't,
I don't know.
I just know there are certain types of music, certain songs that have a transcendent quality.
And that's not just pop songs or classical music.
It could be heavy metal music.
It could be, Oh no, it, it definitely spans genres.
And I, you know, I'll, I'll get on a soapbox later, but I'll let you finish your thought.
I'm just saying like, it allows you to connect with something.
And that feeling of connecting to something trans transcendent, something greater to yourself,
the greater than yourself is, is actually that feeling of connecting more strongly with the collective unconscious.
It's because you're spending that filter.
The music is, is, is allowing you to entrain.
It's, it's entraining you into a state where you suspend that filter.
Go ahead.
In my, I was going to say, and you know, this speaks more predominantly to live or analog music versus digital too,
because you always hear, um, weird album guys like me saying that vinyl sounds better.
And it's not that, you know, we want everybody to spend $10,000 on a crazy turntable.
You can buy a cheap one and still hear the difference.
Um, I think that when it is authentic and natural, you know, you often hear it's warmer or it's more natural.
You have more tendencies to appreciate that.
And I can point to examples of folks that didn't understand this until you play a song that has been digitized versus an analog song.
And they literally can experience that getting lost in the analog a lot easier than they can with the digital.
And, um, just the, the music analogy speaks to me only because again, sort of the genuine article provides a better conduit for people to get into that state than not that it can't happen with the digital, but it's certainly easier.
And now it makes sense too, because the digital is a false representation of what we as biological beings are supposed to hear.
And if there is this collective unconscious that's speaking through that medium, it makes perfect sense because ones and zeros don't translate like 300 sound waves do.
Yeah.
So what we look at the way we look at it is, um, the reality overlay that I was speaking of, you know, instead of saying a matrix, instead of saying a simulation, instead of getting into like the mechanics of it, you know, what civilizations throughout history would say is that this is, they would say the world is illusionary to a certain degree, but they would say it's, it's very dreamlike.
Right.
So you hear this when, when you talk about Aboriginal cultures, you hear this, when you get really, when you go way back, you know, um, to the time of Christ or prior to the time of Christ and Greek culture.
Um, that there's a, you know, the Greek said, this isn't the real world.
And well, a lot of people don't know that they think of the Greek, um, ancient Greek culture was hyper rational.
It was not.
And, or maybe it was, and we just don't understand it.
And they said, you know, this isn't the real world.
The real world is on the other side of the black sun.
Right.
And people have spent thousands of years trying to figure out what the black sun is.
There are some ideas.
Right.
But it's, it's a, that would be a digression from this conversation.
So all of these ancient cultures had this idea and what we would, what we look at it as is being, you know, a collective dream in a sense.
And if there's something that's collectively dreamlike about our reality, then our reality is us.
Right.
Like, and we are, there's gotta be something to it too, because we see this historically.
Uh, like you said, going back to the ancient Greeks, there's patterns of this in the Chinese, ancient Indian, which I love, uh, the, you know, but it also transitions throughout the centuries.
Uh, the biggest example that's setting off bells for me would be Descartes and philosophy.
And then it, you know, we have the modern interpretation that you're presenting today too.
So thousands of years of human history can't be entirely nuts.
Right.
And so what I would say is that this, that feeling of transcendence that you have, right.
That's a feeling of being more connected to who you are.
Right.
That there's, there's a part of yourself that ourselves that we're not connected to on a day to day basis.
And that feeling of transcendence, that collective unconscious is actually a collective unconscious.
It's, it's you, it's me, it's Sadie, it's Bigfoot, it's Lou, it's Mr. Dune and tank, right?
Like that's our collective unconscious.
It's a part of ourself that we, that we can't consciously feel, but we can.
We only get glimpses of it, right?
We don't see it in the totality.
Absolutely.
As a matter of fact, the way that people used to explain it when they talked about it from the Jungian perspective is if you ever had, like when you were a kid in school, if they ever gave you those iron filings and put it on a piece of construction paper, and then you had to put a magnet under it.
Yes.
Right.
The archetypes, right, are the, that we see around us.
So those are the shapes in the filings, but the, the archetypes that we don't see in the collective unconscious,
right?
That's, that's the magnet.
Jung called it the Unus Mundi, the one world, the world we don't see.
We can never directly perceive, but it, it creates the shapes around us.
It's the negative space of our existence.
Which is critically important because when we're overwhelmed or overstimulated, we can't process it.
So it makes perfect sense.
Yeah.
And I mean, to be honest, I think that probably in like a, in a primitive situation, like in a, and I'm not saying this to be disrespectful to Aboriginal people.
I'm just using the term because that's the one that most describes the situation, right?
So in an Aboriginal setting, I think people spend a lot more of their time directly connected to it.
Right.
But we are in constant crisis.
In our modern lives, we're constantly distracted.
We're.
And so I think that of all people, we probably have the least connection to that part of ourselves.
Right.
Unless we go to Brazil and do ayahuasca.
Yeah.
But then like a fifth dimensional demon gets you all fucked up and you quit your job.
Right.
Leave your wife and all that.
Yeah.
So.
Super, super interesting.
Yeah.
I mean, that's just a digression.
That's how it works.
Right.
But the way this connects to the topic today is that the pattern, right?
We call them.
Of course, I'm going to forget now, even though it's very simple, synodic cycles.
So the, the pattern of the planets moving around in a relationship to each other.
So two planets have each time you have two different planets, you have a synodic cycle.
Right.
So in this case, it's Saturn and Neptune.
Their synodic cycle is 36 years.
So they move around the sky and they meet.
And then Saturn moves forward and sort of laps the sun and comes around and meets Neptune again.
Right.
And that synodic cycle rules the materialization of the world out of the collective unconscious.
So that period is one where we see sort of ideas, inventions, social movements, enter the collective consciousness first through the magic.
And these can be positive or negative.
Correct.
Okay.
They go through a series of changes as the planets go through the signs.
And then when we have what we're approaching now, they crystallize.
Right.
Saturn is crystallization and limitation.
They crystallize into a limited and limiting form.
Um, so for instance, if we had ideologies, right.
Cause we touch on this sometimes.
I don't usually touch on it.
I'm not, I'm not political, but we touch on it on X.
Right.
So we have ideologies that develop, they've developed their own unique flavor.
We could look back in history and say, okay, it's like this other movement, but it's not the shore.
Right.
Those develop and they start off in the popular imagination.
And then we have what we're experiencing now where we're seeing them crystallize into their final form, which may not be a form that any of us anticipated consciously.
Right.
Or, or, or maybe what we did, but this is the part, right.
Where the, the karma, the series of actions and choices or seemingly choices that we make.
Right.
Um, during that period are all crystallizing into a, a set form of, uh, positions.
And in our personal lives, right, we have relationships and our relationships are, and the patterns we have of relating are crystallizing into these set forms as well.
So this is all happening right now.
It's going to continue to happen.
And I look at the, the Saturn, Neptune, it's at the Aries point.
Okay.
So that's another like random thing to throw in there.
Uh, what that means is that this is a very unusual one.
This is one that happens only once in a while.
This matter of fact, we think it happens only once every 6,400 years.
That's what the math says, but math isn't always perfect.
Give or take a millennia.
Right.
So whatever happens at one point, that one point in the sky, right, that rules sort of the world.
Cause that, that's the ascendant.
That's the identity point of reality.
Just like a person has an ascendant, an identity point in their astrological chart.
Reality does as well.
And it's zero degrees Aries.
So whatever happens there is very big.
Right.
And it, it, it sort of rules history for a long time.
So this, we're all caught up in normative, enormously biased to a certain degree right now.
Some of us are like, okay, wow, things are really changing.
Others like, oh no, no, this is all the ways, you know, it's always been this way.
However, like the world is really fucking changing right now.
And the changes that the world's going through right now, man, that they're going to stick.
Right.
For good and for ill, they're, they're going to stick.
Sure.
And so what we have going forward over the next couple of years, what we have, once we get past that, that, that conjunction, that hump, those are, those are the final problems.
Right.
We have this sort of, particularly as Americans, right.
We have this, um, perpetual innocence.
Um, right.
We have this like perpetual innocence, hang up.
Like, well, we were innocent.
Like, remember nine 11, like we, America lost its innocence.
Right.
But how many times have we lost our innocence?
Like in my life, it's been like 10 times.
We've lost our innocence.
Right.
And as individuals, the problem is we forget, or we choose to forget as well.
Sure.
And I'm not specifically, you know, saying nine 11 here.
Uh, but every time there is what we would consider one of those innocence lost moments, it's easier to stop acknowledging it than to sort of, I guess, roll with that punch, but not forget the sting.
Right.
So how many times in a person's life, do they have something comparable to that?
How many times you win like a group chat or hanging out with some friends in real life?
Like we used to do.
Right.
And someone does something really stupid or really crass or mean, or, and I'm not saying that in a childish way.
I'm just saying like, as a character trait, right.
They do something that, you know, as adults, we've read X, I apparently do it on the daily.
So, okay.
So, but we just saw it shrug our shoulders.
Like, Oh, it's not that big.
Right.
Because it hasn't been a big deal because we've had particular over the last 36 years, we've had this, this culture, this, this concept that, you know, we're in this perpetual state of innocence.
Everything is just sort of like a, Oh, well, you know, that's a childish, you know, kids will be kids.
I mean, Ryan, I'm, I'm 51 years old and I'm not going to say how old you are, but I know that you're closer to my age than people would guess.
Right.
Correct.
Okay.
I, I, I tend to present much younger than I actually am.
You do.
So I know people my age who behave that same way.
Right.
Like they expect the world to shrug their shoulders at their follies and misdeeds because, Oh, well, kids will be kids, but we're not kids anymore.
And, but there's the other extreme to JT, there are the right fighters and this, this, this, I can at any day point to a dozen examples that are constantly not willing or hypersensitive to events to the point where it empowers us to shrug our shoulders.
Right.
Well, and I'll, I'll put myself out there because I'm an easy target.
If I do something egregious and someone calls me on it, I'm the first one to admit it and say, yeah, that was a fucking stupid or ignorant or terrible thing to do.
Yeah.
But when you are digging and digging and digging for every time Ryan ties his shoelace right over left, instead of leftover, right, it's going to desensitize the masses.
Right.
And again, I'm not being egotistical.
It's just easier to do this on an individual level than it is to think about it across the world, across the country, across the cosmos.
No, and this strikes a particular note because you, I've never looked at your natal chart, but I imagine that I'd see something there that indicates this, that you definitely have a character trait that, that draws an inordinate amount of criticism and judgment to your actions.
But that's okay because I wouldn't be me if I didn't have that.
And so, again, I don't want it to be about me, but I'm just saying, you know, this happens everywhere in the world where there are people that are willing to jump on the smallest thing.
And that empowers that the masses or maybe even the collective unconscious to say, eh, well, none of this is important.
Right.
It's kind of like, yeah.
Okay.
But here's the thing.
What I'm trying to, you're, you're a hundred percent.
Right.
And I think you've explained the internal mechanics of exactly what we've been going through perfectly.
So these are the moments when, okay.
And I, I'll tell you exactly how this might be working out right now.
So that's, I guess that's a, that's not an exact statement, exactly how this might be working out.
Okay.
AI.
Now let's just set aside all the fucking insanity.
Okay.
That AI is bringing into the world right now.
There is really powerful, strong and negative to it, but nobody sees either side of it.
I agree.
So the AI, right, is more than capable and it will be, as we go forward, will be more than capable of making objective analysis of the data that we have self-recorded for ourselves on the internet.
Right.
There's a lot of things.
They're also a recording device.
They're a journal that we enter, you know, all our thoughts and thoughts we shouldn't talk about.
We admit to things we shouldn't admit to, and you know, both good things and bad things.
Right.
You mentioned the invisible data collection that just happens.
Yes.
So that has been building.
Right.
So how long, what's 36 years ago now?
It's what the 1991.
Right.
So this is the exact, yeah.
So it's the exact, the internet age.
Right.
So we have been developing all this intangible, seemingly intangible, not intangible for you, but like in the minds of the majority of people intangible information.
So it's been intangible this entire time.
And we treat it as it's in, as if it's intangible.
But now because of the advances of technology, it is no longer intangible.
That is, it is something that can be scraped, condensed, profiled and use.
That is the karmic deep impact.
That is Saturn conjunct Neptune at the Aries point.
That is.
And I feel terrible because I did it today.
I made a stock trade based on 35 years of chart history.
Just on a whim.
There you go.
But so, look, if I was, if I was to make a judgment of you, and I, you know, I know some of the scandals through the years.
I don't know all of them.
Right.
But I've seen the full time.
Please do.
I'm numb to it.
No.
What I'm saying is, I see both sides.
Right.
I've seen you say things and I'm like, oh, fucking.
And I've, I've told you.
Right.
Online.
I've told you.
Yes.
Ryan.
Are you off your meds?
What the fuck is that?
Right.
I think that people who spend enough time.
Watching your, your stuff will, will recognize that that, that that's an aspect of your personality, but it's not, it's probably not your core personality.
Right.
It's probably not the core of who you are.
Like you, you seem like beneath all of that sort of peripheral stuff, you seem like a decent person.
Okay.
Don't say that.
You're blowing my gimmick.
No, but no one here.
No one here.
Jack left.
The point is, I think people can, can perceive that, um, over time.
However.
Right.
And some people might say something similar about me because believe it or not, people find me to be very confrontational.
And, uh, particularly like in back channels and shit, I get, I get kicked out of group chats all the time.
I get, I've been kicked out of the same two group chats four times in the past two days.
And then people just keep adding.
Kudos to you for going back.
I don't add myself.
People add me because they want me there to fuck with the people they don't like.
Not that I do it intentionally, but my presence alone is enough that other people will leave the group chat.
It's this crazy kind of thing.
Like I'm this, this, uh, uh, hobgoblin right in the minds of, of the spaces hosts on, uh, uh, related to like, uh, UFOs and astrology and shit.
All right.
So people see that about me, but if they get to know me, if they talk to me or if they listen to my spaces, they realize that's one aspect of my personality.
That's not my whole personality.
So I can say that in this case we have, we're in a sort of a similar situation, right?
In different, different areas, but we're in a sort of the new and gaming and me and, and whatever the hell this is I'm involved in here.
Right.
Sure.
So when the technology advances, it probably, let's face it, it has for the government.
Right.
But when private industry has the technology and I'm sure they, so private industry has it now.
Google has it now.
Facebook has it now.
X has it now, but someday, you know, boss Ryan is going to have it.
Right.
Any, quite frankly, anybody that has the bankroll for it has it now.
Yeah.
So, and when that happens, they're going to be able to make these judgments about us related to the sum of the data.
A lot of it, like, you know, they can tell, they can tell psychopaths, not that anyone here is a psychopath.
They can tell psychopaths from looking at the keystrokes they use, looking at how they type on their keyboard, the words they choose, the spelling errors they make, the force which they touch their keystrokes, their fingers to the keyboard.
So they already know that.
Right.
Now, like the NSA doesn't give that, or whoever has it, doesn't give that information to your boss.
But someday your boss is going to know.
Right.
Someday, this is all going to be laid bare.
And it's probably a lot closer than any of us suspect.
So that's the karma.
Right.
That's the, the, the past actions coming back to us in a tangible way.
And we all have to, right.
Right.
We all have to start to look at each other from a compassionate perspective as you, as you were intimating, because we're all in that situation.
Like, I'm sure I am the worst offender.
Right.
We know that you've, you've had your own issues.
I'm sure everyone here is nothing close to where we are, as far as like getting ourselves caught in jams online and, you know, saying stupid things or writing things we shouldn't write or, you know, spending 18 hours at an end looking at crazy websites that probably get you put on a government.
Right.
Okay.
So they're probably not in the same category, but we all are.
We all are.
We all have one foot in that category.
And, you know, the machines aren't going to have compassion for us.
Right.
They might be fair.
I'm not saying that they're not fair.
I'm not.
I was going to say it.
Compassion might be overrated in that situation because they are going to be absolutely objective.
Yes, that's true.
But, you know, we might find it's just like when we're talking about the medical system, which is another case of this karmic deep impact, which is.
Oh, they would have offed me years ago.
I'm too expensive.
Yes.
So, you know, we are all right.
We're all facing this collective and individual karma in all of these areas in the medical system and information technology.
And if we don't have in politics, in, you know, dealing with the entitlement or lack of a time of the social safety net, whatever you want to call it, dealing with international relations, dealing in our families, in our relationships, in our marriages, if we're married.
And I think that the machines are going to be completely objective.
Right.
But that, again, that should cause us to, in my opinion, right, we may have a disagreement on that.
But in my opinion, that, that calls for us to develop greater compassion for each other, because God only knows, like, who, among us, who hasn't done some crazy shit on the internet, or we'll see that life decisions that jeopardize their health, let them throw the first stone.
See, and this is where I think it's not necessarily disagreement or on the same highway, just in different lanes, right?
Yeah.
I welcome the objectivity, because what it's going to do is it's going to more easily expose agitators on both ends that are extreme.
You know, and we talked about the Karen that's going to nitpick every single thing, right, that her neighbor does, right?
That is going to be quantitatively worse than the person that, you know, maybe told someone to go fuck themselves every once in a while.
Yeah.
And that's where I welcome that objectivity, because, let me tell you, I've had more than my fair share of people that stalk every move that I have.
And the level of, I guess, the level of dedication that they have is great.
But when it comes to an objective perspective, and when it sorts out in the data, so to speak, we got problems.
And it's not we, it's they have problems, because they are creating this scenario that's going to be negative for them.
And I guess my compassion comes in where I don't want to see that, for horsing around on the internet and talking about elves.
Come on.
So.
No, you know, that's an excellent example, because you're right, there are a lot of people who, I mean, I would call the crazies, right?
That's me not being as compassionate as I should be, but it's just how I look at it, right?
There are crazies out there.
I tried to tiptoe around that, but it really is an obsession.
Sure.
You, hey, you get it bad, but you know who really gets it is Venger.
Have you seen that through the years?
Oh.
I've seen, all you've got to do is mention Venger on the right subreddit, and they come out of the woodwork.
I just talked to Venger yesterday, and holy smokes.
Every day of his life, every time he logs on online.
Of course, you know, he does bring it on himself a little bit, right?
His self-promotion, right?
That's his persona, right?
Right.
Cultivating himself to look like Anton LaVey.
But what difference does it make?
It's online.
It's 2020.
And at the end of the day, anybody that looks at Venger in totality...
Right, knows, yeah.
...finds out that he is the nicest guy.
I'll give you an example.
We're doing a giveaway for Valentine's Day.
We're going to try to do it every year now.
We did it last year as sort of a one-off, and people said, "This was great.
It was really in the spirit of the hobby."
We just talked to our creative friends and say, "Hey, can you throw something into the kitty?"
I gain absolutely nothing from it other than making a lot of people in the hobby happy.
Venger saw it, reached out to me, and said, "Ryan, I'm going to send you not two or three books.
I'm going to send you a case of stuff."
On his own.
He is a nice guy.
The haters that go after him, they almost have blinders on that they refuse to see that kind of stuff, right?
No, he is.
You're right.
He is a nice guy.
He did once.
He gave me a free...
When I was down and out, he gave me a free product once.
One of his...
Chalt!
Yeah.
Anyway.
Free plug, Venger.
Sure.
And also, you've got to remember to mention that he's got pallets of these books in his basement.
I wasn't going to go there, JT.
You did that.
His wife, four men seem to get rid of them.
So, you give the opportunity.
You want to give away some free stuff?
Oh, yeah, take it.
My wife is going to kill me if you don't take this stuff.
Look, I try to tell a great story about Venger.
Here you go.
No, I mean...
Okay, so the thing is, though, if you get beyond your personal ideological differences, right?
Like, I don't agree with...
I'm not on that train, right?
I'm not on the train with some of the stuff he's into.
But as a human being, aside from that, right?
And we used to...
If you remember, Ryan, there was a time in our youth, we had like one golden moment, right?
Where we actually judged other people based on whether we thought they were a cool person
or not, and not every other thing, right?
Right.
You could meet someone, and you might...
You know, at first, you might be like, "Oh, okay.
This...
I don't know what's up with this person."
And you talk to them a little bit.
They're a nice person.
Hey, that's great.
You know?
Now you're friends."
And of course, part of that was being young, but it was also the moment.
It was that...
And it was interpersonal.
It was removed from this online sphere that we have now.
Oh, absolutely.
The online sphere is absolutely...
But again, the karma.
This is it.
The online sphere.
Right.
The social media has created this intense collective karmic burden.
And karmic is consequences.
That's what it means.
It's just intense series of delayed consequences.
So, when we look at karma, just so everyone else will know, I know we're getting...
I don't know.
Your deep astrology knowledge will probably top you off for the day.
But the effect of Saturn, right?
When I say it's limitations, right?
The way the ancients looked at it was that Saturn was the evil machinations that lie in ambush.
It was like setting traps.
Right.
So, from my perspective, when they said Saturn ruled time, well, time is a trap that comes
from us all, right?
Like one day, you're running around, you're fine.
The next day, you're like looking at your beard.
What the hell is that?
Do I have something wrong with my beard?
Right?
You come in there.
And it's the first white hair in your beard.
So...
JT, I don't want to cut you short, but I'm going to have a hard stop like in a minute.
Because I'm going to have three children screaming in the car.
Dude, I really appreciate you coming in and being supportive.
All I was saying is that karma is the same thing.
It's a trap, right?
The unfulfilled consequences or unmet consequences of past actions that follow us and just wait
for the right moment to materialize.
But hey, look, I really appreciate talking to you.
I absolutely agree.
I hope we'll talk again sometime.
You know?
I can hop in and lurk probably more than you notice me when there's more people here.
Yeah.
So, you know what we should do sometime?
And I know February is going to be tight, but maybe after that.
Yeah.
Maybe we can...
You can come on Nerd Cognito and we can talk about that connection that we talked about
before specific to gaming on like a 101 level.
Yeah.
I'm the only person on Earth who has the chart for...
I mean, not everyone should, but no one has an interest.
So I'm the only astrologer on Earth who has the chart for RPG gaming.
That's awesome.
All right.
JT, I want to thank you for the conversation.
Yeah.
I'm still going to listen, but I'm going to hop out now before the kids make it so you
can't hear me.
All right.
Cool, Ryan.
Talk to you later, man.
See you, buddy.
So that was nice of Ryan too.
I was floundering.
I was going to call it a day because everyone here is great.
I just, I got to almost 15 minutes with no one showing up.
One person showed up and he stood, was around for 15 seconds and took off.
Right.
So I'm trying to, yeah.
Okay.
So it was great of Ryan and Jack who was awesome with them.
Ryan does a podcast called Nerd Cognito.
He does a lot of gaming related stuff.
He's, he's a spokesman for the classic gaming community.
The, the gaming that we enjoyed in our youth, as opposed to the modern gaming.
He's a little more political than I am.
I'm nonpolitical, but at his core, I think that he's just about trying to recapture that,
you know, that, that period of time.
And yeah, I mean, cause things have changed a lot and you know, we, you get older, right?
You feel like you're losing.
Maybe everyone else doesn't feel like they're losing.
Maybe they, they, they don't appreciate what you once had cause they never had it.
Um, I, I definitely identify with that and I've been a lifelong gamer and, uh, particularly
since my accident, I got back into it and I, you know, I watched Ryan stuff and, uh, interact
with him a lot online.
So yeah.
Uh, does anyone else want to come up and speak?
Um, I know Bigfoot and Lou, I'm not saying you have to speak.
I sent you invitations in case you wanted to, because I'm so bad at managing the, the,
the, um, the spaces that in case somebody wanted to speak and I didn't know, like I
wouldn't know, you know, I know that I'm just repeating myself.
Right.
So I just send people sometimes just in case they want to, but that doesn't mean I expect
you to come up.
I always enjoy talking to both of you, particularly, you know, we'll do with the reviewing stuff
of Bigfoot.
You always have with a few times we've talked, you've had some great stuff to say.
So the thing about this, the reason this is so important, um, although we sort of, we're
looking sort of a very broad picture there, right?
Saturn conjunct Neptune at the Aries point is hitting bottom.
It's the world hitting bottom.
It's, it's humanity hitting bottom.
And if anyone can hear me and you want to throw up like a sign or something, just in
case I want to make sure I'm not losing anyone now that Ryan isn't here to give me feedback.
Um, so as we approach this bottom, right, uh, next month, you know, it's going to last the very, very bottom.
It's going to last about three years.
And we've done spaces before talking about the Astro RV project, uh, run by Josh, Josh Maitland of Rockstar remote viewing and Dan Waits of world astrology review, both relatively new to what they do, but very knowledgeable individuals.
Um, and there was a little bit of mistake instead of viewing one day, they viewed three, three years worth of data.
Um, no one consulted me or Morgan.
And that's why the mistake occurred.
Um, and they saw, you know, they saw an escalation of war.
They saw civil unrest revolutions breaking out.
They saw a coastal event involving perhaps, perhaps a weapon being used in the ocean causing some coastal flooding, but a lot of flooding events and a lot of political turmoil, social turmoil.
Um, those are all things that we would expect during this transit, right?
So it's important for us as individuals to be aware of these larger dangers.
So if you start to see signs, right, like you start to see signs of the war escalating and you wonder if it's going to affect you, it is.
Okay.
Now it doesn't mean it's going to affect you now before you see the signs, but if you start to see the signs, right, even more so than we have now.
Right.
And there's something you can do to better your situation.
Then you should do that.
Um, if you start to see indications of flooding in your area or earthquakes or in some places, volcanoes, believe it or not, they're going to be volcano issues.
We started to see that in areas where there are volcanoes.
There are no volcanoes in New England, so I can't speak from personal experience, but I have seen it happening on the news.
So if there's some indication that that might happen in your area, you should take it very seriously.
But particularly in the United States, because this, this transit is occurring conjunct the USIC or very close to a exact conjunction with the USIC.
And that is the spot in the chart relates that relates to home.
So with the individual, it relates to their, their parents, their house, anything below ground, um, a family graves mines.
It can, it can relate to mining now.
Okay.
That sounds fun.
Like I start to laugh and go, Oh, with mines, because when it shows up in an individual's chart, right?
Um, very rarely do you find that their family is involved in mining or they have a mine, um, at their family home.
But this, this transit right now, this is a great opportunity to display this, that the IC relates to mines because what is the obsession that the US government has right now?
Right.
Rare earth minerals under the ground.
I'm not, I'm not political.
You can't be political and be in my opinion and be, uh, an honest broker in these areas, like, uh, uh, an honest forecaster.
Okay.
Or honestly process RV data, et cetera.
I'm just pointing out that, right.
The US is in a conflict with the European union union that might split up NATO over rare earth elements in Greenland.
So that's something that was brought up five or six years ago, but it's not something that most people would have foreseen for this, you know, for the present moment.
Oil is also ruled by Neptune.
So what's going on in Venezuela, what's going on in Greenland, right?
Those events are strongly correlated to the fact that this transit, this karmic deep impact transit, right, is, is going to be nearly exact with the point in the US chart that represents our country, our people.
Um, the homeland is a physical thing.
And I don't, I use, I grew up before the people use the term homeland.
I always use it.
I mean, not just, it's not disrespectful, but like in a, in a non disrespectful, ironic sense, because for me, like, it's still kind of odd.
Um, but yes, the physical United States.
So for people who are physically in the United States, this transit can represent, um, a very heavy burden for Americans.
And, um, particularly once we get into June and July, when Uranus moves into Gemini, really strongly crystallized, really solidly crystallized divisions in the US between the, the two dominant cultures.
Um, if not even more divisions.
So, um, on a world stage, as we enter the summer, we're going to see people squaring off.
We're going to see China and Russia, if they're still allied and Iran, and, you know, we're going to see them, if they're all still around and still allied, it's going to be more public.
Right.
And who the U S will eventually remain allied to.
That's going to be something that we're going to see physically as this summer goes on.
Like if the U S is going to leave NATO, we're going to know.
Right.
Once Uranus moves back into Gemini and the world begins bifurcating, splitting it to two parties.
But as of now, we're going to see the toll that's due.
We're going to see our hopes and dreams, um, get a big reality check.
We're seeing that now.
We're going to see it more.
So in the next couple of months, we're going to see our, our nightmares solidified to some degree.
And for some of us, okay, for some of us, we will see, um, dream solidify.
So that, you know, that is something that can happen.
It's, it's less likely to happen, but there are some people who will see, um, events in their life that solidify.
So if we look at like political division, it's something that most of us don't want, but there are some people that's their dream.
Okay.
There's always another side to the coin.
So some people will see dreams solidify into reality, knowing that this is going to happen, allows you to judge the most likely scenario for in your own life.
And for the people around you, people are going through a struggle that you can really strongly anticipate.
They're going to hit bottom this year, probably this spring, right?
If you're going through a struggle, you can really strongly anticipate depending on where it is in your chart.
But just in general, if you don't know your chart, you can really strongly anticipate that these problems are going to hit bottom.
You can really strongly anticipate that, um, you might have an opportunity.
Okay.
So there's the flip side.
You might have an opportunity to crystallize something creative into a physical form.
If you're someone like Ryan, um, and I'm sure the rest of you guys have things you're working on.
Sadie always writes posts, awesome posts every day.
I see awesome posts, awesome posts after awesome posts, after awesome posts.
I'm like, I like that.
I like that.
Right.
If you're a creative person, um, this will present an opportunity for you to crystallize that creativity into something, depending on what area it is in your chart, right?
It could be a relationship.
It could be a venture.
Um, it could be a job.
It could be all kinds of things.
Um, but that is possible, but generally the general trend is going to be a burden.
Um, and the response will be, uh, sort of an aggressive surge forward to, uh, create, create, yeah, correct those differences to, um, to rectify perceived injustices.
This is a crusading period of time.
And the thing about that is everyone is going to perceive that the injustice is different.
Right.
So this is the period where you anticipate more than one army, for instance, you know, it could be more than one faction at work.
It could be more than one person in a relationship.
It could be brothers and sisters in a family, depending, but you know, to use a general analogy, this is the point where you have two armies who truly believe that what they're doing is the right thing.
Right.
That truly believe that they're going to war for good against evil.
This is that type of moment.
Um, Neptune and Saturn, Saturn and Neptune in Aries, Saturn and Neptune conjunctions usually, um, usually correlate with major developments in Russian civilization.
Uh, there are different reasons for that, or people speculate different reasons for that, but it is consistent historically.
Right.
And when, um, when Saturn and Neptune conjunct in, in Aries, Russia generally, this, okay.
So I, this is something we won't, we don't want to misunderstand, but generally speaking during these periods, Russia is victorious in some sort of military endeavor.
Um, that doesn't necessarily mean that there's going to be like one, one side will just collapse.
Um, and the funny thing about these, these, this, this type of scenario, like if you look at world war two, where at the end of the war you had, or at through the war, right.
You had a number of nations change sides.
Okay.
So, um, you know, Italy, Italy was victorious throughout the entire war because as soon as, uh, the allies became ascendant, Italy switched and became an allied nation.
That's not to criticize them.
I'm just saying like, this is an example.
So we say like, this is a period where Russia will be victorious.
I mean, who knows what that means at this point, right?
We'll know in a couple of years, but it could be that, uh, there's an internal problem in Russia and the people feel they're victorious over their previous government.
Um, however, it could also mean that, um, that Russia will come out on top of a geopolitical conflict as well.
Right.
This is a period where empires tend to fall.
And because this is the Aries point, this is a period where a global empire could experience a fall.
Um, we are so rich compared to previous people, previous civilizations.
We have experienced a series of milestones of civilizational collapse and we've shrugged them off.
I'll give an example.
And I don't mean to offend anyone, depending on how people feel about this particular, um, phenomenon.
But when the Russian society was collapsing, the Soviet union was collapsing.
We see this in other historical, um, collapses of civilizations as well, but this is recent.
In my lifetime, uh, there was a huge uptick in prostitution.
Prostitution was incredibly common, um, during that period of time in the former Soviet union.
And as common as it was when they would pull people, even more women said that they would participate in it if given the opportunity.
Now this isn't to say that they were bad people or that it's bad.
I'm not, I'm not making a value judgment.
I'm not saying sex work is bad.
I'm saying it's good.
I'm not saying anything about that.
What I'm saying is because of the financial desperation of a collapsing civilization, insecurity of collapsing state and the high inflation, right?
What was normative behavior changed.
Now the same, we always anticipated astrologers that the same thing would happen in the U S or some of us did.
But when it happened in the U S it came in the form of only fans.
So we've gone through that stage of a society's collapse, but in a unique American version where everyone stays in the house.
And people are just, um, participating in sex work online.
And if you look at it from that perspective, and if you have any connection to the younger generations, uh, you will know that, uh, particularly amongst women who have greater opportunity.
Um, in that area, uh, it's extremely common.
Like I have connections in the restaurant industry from when that was my side hustle.
Right.
And if you're in one of these nice restaurants where, you know, um, you expect a certain caliber of person.
And I don't mean that as a personal judgment.
I'm saying that's the judgment that the, that the restaurant makes management makes.
Um, if you're in a place where everyone is, you know, well put together and good looking again, you know, I'm not, I'm not trying to say that that makes someone a better person.
I'm just saying that that's, you know, if you go to a certain place, you pay a certain amount of money, then you generally have attractive staff.
It's, it's, it's an unpleasant reality or a pleasant reality, depending on how one looks at it.
Um, almost every, almost every young woman there is, has had an only fountains account.
I mean, it's at least in this area in, in Massachusetts, in New England, that may be different, but a million.
We're talking about millions of young American women.
Now, when we talk about this karmic deep impact, right.
And we talk about the effect of having 30 years of online data about us all compiled.
And that's something that they will carry with them for the rest of their lives.
And that's, that's something that we're talking about.
And that's something that we're talking about.
Is that they will have to deal personally with the consequences of that action.
At least here in some areas in the United States.
Influences in general.
Now that's a longer term trend.
But influences in general are the petty aristocracy of our modern age.
And just like the last time we went through this series of, or a similar series of planetary alignments during the Revolutionary War,
the world sort of purged itself in stages one area after the other of petty aristocrats.
We can look at influences themselves probably not experiencing the same level of pushback from the population,
but definitely becoming sort of a fading phenomenon without a doubt.
And that's beginning in the United States right now.
And that's something we can all associate with what we see on X on Instagram with the constant complaints from everyone that they're being throttled.
Accounts with 300,000 followers, you know, saying they're shadow banned.
Because they're just not getting as many views as they used to.
This is definitely something that's ongoing as we speak.
But what I'm trying to say is that we can't say, if I say global civilization is collapsing, then I'm also saying that, you know, my own nation in some respect is a collapsing civilization.
I'm not trying to say that in an unpatriotic way.
I'm not making judgments about it.
Some people see it as being a positive thing.
They see it as a return to the time when the country was better, before we became an international power.
But the evidence is that we are declining as an international power.
We're retrenching.
We're moving back into this hemisphere and moving, you know, removing ourselves from the rest of the world if this trend continues.
From a historian's perspective, that will be looked at as an empire collapsing.
That doesn't mean that we're all going to be destitute on the street.
Right?
And that's not just Americans, but anywhere in Western civilization.
That does not mean that's going to be the case because we are so affluent.
But we will not be as affluent as we have been compared to historical norms.
We've already seen that.
Ryan and I were talking about that earlier.
We already see this happening with inflation.
We have problems in healthcare.
We have problems with employment.
We're returning to the historical mean.
And that's going to continue.
That's part of the karmic deep impact and the collapse of whatever we were as a global empire back into being a regional power or a hemispheric power.
So what's the bright side?
Well, the bright side of karmic deep impact, the bright side of the, and I spoke about this in my last space as well, and I'm probably going to bring it up again prior to this all completing, all being fulfilled.
So, there have been a number of prophecies, predictions, eschatological forecasts.
There have been a whole host of grifters who've come forward in recent years predicting that we're going to experience some sort of massive, large scale spiritual unfolding over the next few years, particularly in 2026.
As a matter of fact, the predictions began in 2025.
There were people a hundred years ago, farther back than a hundred years ago, specifically predicting that the world would begin to change in a spiritual sense in 2025.
There are other individuals talking about 2026.
And as those of us who have some contact with the UFO community know, there are UFO community specific predictions about the unfolding of a great spiritual knowledge in 2026.
Now, from an astrological standpoint, that is true.
I believe that some of those individuals are grifters who appropriated astrological predictions and turned them into alleged extraterrestrial prophecies.
I can't prove that.
That's what I believe.
Those astrological predictions were certainly there.
And a skilled astrologer could have made these predictions a thousand years ago or 2000 years ago for this period of time.
It's just, it's written in the stars.
It's, it is likely that there's going to be some kind of spiritual awakening.
I don't think it's going to be what, to the same degree others think it is.
Well, no.
I think it's going to be like strong, but in a limited number of people.
I think that the, a lot of the, a lot of these fields aren't good for growing anything anymore.
Right.
A lot of people are no longer receptive to the collective unconscious.
They're no longer receptive to spiritual themes.
And there are a number of reasons for that nature and nurture and media and, and pharmacological.
But amongst the people who are receptive, I think that there's, there's a strong possibility.
There's going to be a massive spiritual awakening to, to a new knowledge or a forgotten knowledge.
People again, jump on this bandwagon.
You can find a lot of people on X relating to their own.
Earlier today, I saw the ethical skeptic account saying that his geometry of ancient archeological sites was the, this new spiritual knowledge that was going to spread across the, the earth.
Um, I, I don't believe that's accurate.
I think that these people are appropriating this, this time period.
I think that these, um, they almost have to jump on the, on the bandwagon.
They almost have to like make their claim at this point because everyone is expecting something to occur.
Um, I don't think any of them are right, but I think something is going to happen.
So if you are interested in the crystallization of a new spiritual knowledge, um, or, uh, a new form of spirituality, potentially a spiritual leader, that is true.
We don't want to focus on that because, you know, uh, astrology, spirituality, metaphysics is about the wave, not the point, right?
Just like light is a point and a wave, right?
We're, we're really talking about the wave.
We're not talking about the point.
However, our society is super fixated on the point.
So it's possible there could be a genuine new spiritual leader.
Um, but more than likely, we're just looking at a, a saturation, um, from the collective unconscious into certain individuals.
And I don't know what that will look like.
I mean, it's, it happened, um, not that anyone will ever replace Jesus.
There's only one Jesus, only one son of God, but it happened in, in the time of Christianity.
It happened, uh, during the time of Buddha.
It happened in, in, um, in Iran when Zoroaster was there.
Like we've seen some examples and because of the magnitude, the importance of this conjunction,
because it's at the world point zero degrees Aries.
Um, we're looking at something that would have a long-term global influence.
So if that is important and could that include UFOs?
Yeah, absolutely.
People have seen UFOs.
Uh, Josh Maitland saw UFOs.
I don't know if there's, I happen to be in the camp that thinks that there probably isn't anything good.
Spiritually that comes out of the UFO phenomenon, but there are people who certainly disagree.
So it could certainly be related to UFOs.
Um, it could be related to dreams, right?
It could just start having a number of people like, you know, 10, 15% of the population begin like having really powerful dreams, inventive dreams, um, downloading information from the collective conscious, uh, prophetic dreams, just all kinds of dreams.
So that, that would be one possible, um, manifestation of this, um, this transit, this synodic conjunction.
It's not really transit because it's in the mundane sky as opposed to in a person's natal chart.
So there is, if you are interested in spirituality, there is an upside, right?
If you, like most people support the status quo and the most important thing is the main maintenance of the status quo and maintenance of your life and your existence.
And, you know, the, the things that you can hold in your hand, then this is not a good period for you more than likely some people, but for most, this is going to be a tough period.
If you are somebody who has been waiting your entire life for the world to change, the world is going to change.
It's not necessarily going to change for the better immediately.
It could very well, it could be a lot worse for a couple of years, but it should become obvious to us.
If there is an avenue that the world is going to change for the better at some point in the future, that should become apparent now, or we should be able to see that as this crystallization occurs.
So there is that to look forward to, right?
This is the beginning of a new karmic cycle.
So as Neptune begins to move through, through Aries, right?
We'll see the beginning of the, of a series of downloads from the collective unconscious that will then precipitate as Neptune moves through the, Neptune and Saturn move through the signs, right?
So it will start out as a, as a, as an outburst or some sort of spiritual movement.
And then it will, you know, it will become focused on, on the land and, and material things that moves the Taurus.
It will enter Gemini and it will become, you know, bifurcated in some way, divided in some way.
And then it will move through cancer and it will, and there'll be the same spiritual impulse will, you know, and the same series of downloads from the collective unconscious will impact people's home life.
Right.
So it goes from, you know, Leo, children, you know, and things that bring you pleasure and, um, Virgo will be work and, um, and marriage for the, you know, for, for women, wives, right?
So it will go like that until eventually it gets to Pisces and it'll be like what we've, what we've experienced over the last 12 to 14 years, right?
So it's a big sort of soup of, um, imagination and changing values and, um, sort of, um, a period where everything that has come through the collective unconscious, everything that we've imagined and dreamed or feared has all, you know, flowed together into one big soup or ocean, Pisces, right?
That we've immersed ourselves in during this period of time.
So we've seen it all, right?
We've seen it, things that to some of us were very strange become reality.
And I would imagine that depending, no matter what your position is, no matter what your culture is, you've seen things that, that you consider very strange, um, sort of emerge into reality.
Things that you never believed would happen.
That's Neptune in Pisces.
So this is the beginning of that cycle, but it's also the culmination of the, of the, of the past cycle all over the next year, you know, a couple of years, right?
But we're going to see it.
So when people say, well, um, I'm not interested in the wave.
I want to know the point, uh, when Pluto and Saturn were conjunct or formed their conjunction, um, which signaled the onset of COVID.
Um, Pluto and Saturn signals the onset of a pandemic.
So it happened at the beginning of the AIDS pandemic, for instance.
And prior to that, there was like a swine flu, right?
Going back.
So, um, Pluto and Saturn were conjunct on or formed their exact conjunction on January 11th, 2020 and January 12th, 2020 COVID made the news.
So we knew the next day.
Now there is one factor that might change that here.
Well, you know, one mitigating factor.
We might not know exactly everything on the 21st, not the beginning of exactly.
We might not see the exact beginning of everything on the 21st.
Um, Mars will form a conjunction with this point in, I think it's May.
I'm getting tired now because I've talked for a while and I did not sleep last night.
So I think it's May, but at some point in the spring and I will, I will know that for the next space.
So if we don't see exactly what the major issues are going to be the day after or the week after, right?
In late February, we're going to see them when Mars forms that conjunction.
Um, maybe to the day.
So that's sort of our window where we're going to see like the breadth of the beginning of the situation that we all kind of see it now because this transit has been operable since July.
So everything that's come up since July, right?
They're all fitting into basic categories, the war, uh, aliens, right?
With the three eye Atlas, um, natural disasters, oceanic disasters, you know, things like that.
Um, we've had that advantage.
They did not have that.
Uh, we, we did not have that during, um, Saturn conjunct Pluto.
It was a one and done.
So we've had this sort of intro period, which we don't always have, uh, but that will crystallize into distinct form, uh, between February and May.
Right.
And then we're going to know, and then we know the, we know what we have to deal with.
We know who's going to have to deal with it.
And then it's off to the battle, right?
Whatever that means for individuals.
I'm, I'm peaceful.
I don't, you know, like I say, I always reiterate, I'm not political.
I'm not against the government.
I'm not against anyone.
And I'm, um, a conscientious objector type of person.
So for me, the battle is entirely spiritual.
You know, for other people, the battle is going to be very real and physical.
And I wish that were not the case.
Right.
And I hope more people will choose to embrace nonviolence and join whatever aspect of the battle.
Like I find myself in, but I'm okay if it's just me.
Right.
Um, so that's the story.
Uh, I have not seen any sign that anyone can hear me since Ryan left right now.
Ryan is still listed as a speaker and he hasn't been a speaker for a while.
I've got Sadie listed as a listener, Mr. Dune, Lou, Bigfoot and Tank.
That could be other people listening that I can't see on my screen because X froze the screen.
The people that are on my screen may have left and I could be talking to myself.
Oh, one request to speak.
Oh, there is someone.
Oh, Melissa, you're here.
Awesome.
I'm approving you, Bigfoot.
All right.
So I have now seen the updated scene, the screen.
Some of the people that I was talking to are gone.
Now, Lou is a speaker, but Bigfoot is not.
I thought I just approved Bigfoot.
So I don't know.
Lou, that's great.
I love talking to you.
Bigfoot, I'm sorry.
I don't know if there was confusion there or what.
Sinan, welcome.
Melissa, it's great to see you.
So yeah, my screen had been frozen that entire time since Ryan left.
And I didn't, I didn't see any indication anyone was even still here.
Thought I might've been talking to myself.
What's up, Lou?
Let's do it.
Hey man, how's it going?
Oh, it's going great.
I didn't sleep last night, but all things.
Yeah.
I think everyone's got this weird feeling at the moment.
There's something in the air for the past few years.
Yeah.
Oh, there's something big around the corner.
Yeah, definitely, yeah.
But this year really feels like it.
And I don't know what it is.
Yeah.
Dreams are fucked up.
People are, yeah.
Everyone's at each other's throats.
It's Neptune conjunct Saturn, but yeah.
Go on.
Yeah.
But one of the gist of what you're saying essentially is, so everyone's going to face their own karma, whether good or bad, but at the same time, we're going to actually be dealing with everyone else's karma simultaneously.
And, you know, all the governments around the world and all that karma, everything that's been built up, that's been put in motion over the years is all going to come to a head for everyone simultaneously.
Well, you see it happening on X right now.
I mean, if one doesn't perceive it, it's because one is experiencing normalcy bias.
Like there are people on X every day who laugh and make jokes about all the idiots who think we're going to experience World War III.
We've been fighting World War III since 2021, right?
2020, depending, right?
I mean, it's, but there are people out there who still laugh about it.
So there are definitely people who are blind to this, but yeah, this is what's going on.
And those of us who are sensitive, and I think that includes everyone who's here right now, sees this happening in their life.
Hey, Bigfoot, there you are.
What's up, man?
Hey, JT.
Yeah, I made it up here.
Cool.
Yeah, I definitely think there'll be a big spiritual awakening this year.
I feel it.
I kind of see it just in how I see things.
Yeah.
And, you know, as far as war and everything, you know, I mean, you know, it's all spiritual for me at this point.
It has been for a while, you know, you know, everybody, everyone wants to point a rifle around, you know, just, you know, tell me who to point the rifle at.
I mean, I don't think anybody can, can really do that at this point, you know, it's just, it's just all profit.
It's just all a game at this point, you know, just, just everybody wants to be on top.
And they're just sort of the enemy of my enemy is, is my friend, but they all want to be on top.
So, you know, it's just crumbling and falling.
Yeah.
I think everyone has a similar feeling to that.
Hey, can I, you know, I'm going to just play off your name for a second to mention something I didn't mention earlier.
This would also be one of the signs of the time that we're in.
And this is something that people predicted years ago, if not hundreds of years ago, because sometimes it's hard to say exactly what the provenance of a prediction is.
But at least a hundred years ago, people were predicting that one of the signs of our times would be the appearance of strange animals.
Now, I don't know if you guys follow like that side of X where they, where they post about the new animals being discovered or the weird animals, the white moose, the white deer, or, you know, the white Iberian links in Spain and new types of marsupials.
They found, they just found tree kangaroos they thought were extinct, but almost every week there is a new type of animal and, or new to us.
And what's strange about it is you would think the most interesting looking animals would be the ones that would be most common to us.
That would be the thing that attracted us the most, but it turns out as some sort of strange hiccup in the reality overlay that the most exotic looking animals are the ones that we don't see very regularly because all of these animals are very exotic.
And this is the crystallization of, of, of Saturn and Neptune.
These cryptids or pseudo cryptids crystallizing out of our imaginations into reality.
That doesn't mean they haven't always physically been there, but they weren't physically there in our awareness, right?
They weren't in videos.
They weren't, you know, people weren't holding them in front of the camera.
So what would be super, super Saturn conjunct Neptune at the Aries point would be if someone caught a Bigfoot.
I'm not saying it will happen, but I'm saying like, if you wanted to find like the paranormal, right?
If you wanted to say like, what would be like the, the paranormal epitome of this transit, it would be someone standing next to either a living or dead Bigfoot on the news.
Like that would be the epitome of this from a, from a, um, paranormal slash cryptid perspective.
So I'm not saying it will happen, but don't be surprised.
Like this is the type of thing where don't be surprised if that happens.
You know, what's interesting about that is I've noticed, uh, over the past two years, the interest online, uh, on YouTube and X about cryptids has gone through the roof.
I mean, I wasn't even interested in it a couple of years ago when I started to get into the big, down the Bigfoot rabbit hole.
And I was like, holy shit.
I think there's something to this.
Uh, and then it's just, it's blown up the amount of interest in cryptids and the different varieties of them that people are having actually experiences with.
And I've listened to so many interviews and, you know, you can smell bullshit like a fart in a car, like anyone that's got half a brain.
So, you know, when someone's spinning you a yarn, but like people are having some serious experiences over the past couple of years, or they've had them over the past 10 years.
And they're only now got the courage to speak about it, but there's something definitely going on.
Yeah.
A hundred percent.
I, I always think of one of the prophecies that I was referring to, um, was it's called the man with the red hat.
It's a Hopi prophecy.
Oh, sorry.
It's the blue star Kachina.
The man with the red hat and the blue star Kachina are like the two, um, big eschatological prophecies.
So the, the blue star Kachina, anyhow, one of the, they talk about like events prior to this culminating period, right?
Like their end times aren't the end.
They're like this culmination.
And they talk about those animals, right?
They talk about like, they're going to be animals that you've never seen.
Um, you're going to see them all the time.
Right.
Something interesting.
Now, when I first read those, those prophecies, when I was, I don't know, I mean, it was like the early to mid nineties, right?
When you, when you're far from the, the realization of, of prophecies and predictions, sometimes it can seem really strange.
And one of the things they talked about, they said, look, like cities are like anthills and they're hollow places inside where hollow people live.
And they said, and towards the end of time, you'll begin to see a certain type of person on the street, a hollow person who's lost their soul.
And the way they move will be as if they're weighed down by a great burden that will bend them over as they move around.
These hollow people who will congregate in the center of cities towards the period of this culmination.
Now, this is not a value judgment.
It's not, I'm not saying this to judge those individuals.
You're talking about, you're talking about the federal people.
A hundred percent.
Yeah.
That's crazy.
Sure.
In 1992, 1993, if you would ask me to explain that, I couldn't.
It was only when I looked back at that last year that I said, oh shit, that, that, that, that's, that's a hundred percent accurate.
Um, and I have a friend in Denver and they call them weird walkers.
Right.
Which is probably not the best thing, but, um, yeah, we, we, we call our area the methanol, uh, methanol mile.
Um, and I just so happen because I was in an accident.
Um, and I just so happened because I was in an accident.
I sort of became this permanent patient in the, um, the charity hospital because the charity hospital here, Boston Medical Center is also the hospital that is adept with dealing with trauma and the ramifications of trauma because poor people tend to get hit by cars more often.
They also tend to get shot or stabbed more often.
Right.
So when you have a, a, a great physical trauma, they, they just send you to one of these hospitals.
Then you're pretty much stuck in the system from there on.
So I go to this hospital a couple of times a month.
Um, and in order to get through it, you have to drive through like going through a gauntlet, you have to drive through new market square, which is the method of mile.
And it is, you know, Boston is one of the, we've had an immense fentanyl issue and Massachusetts had on a per capita basis.
I think the most fentanyl deaths in the country.
Um, I've known people, like I've known a lot of people and it's strange at my age to, to know people who've died of fentanyl, but I have, um, and a lot of them younger, but some of them my own age.
And, uh, when I'm talking about a number of people down there, dude, I'm not talking about 30 people.
Right.
I'm talking about a thousand, 2,000 people down there in that, in that area, just, you know, with that walk, you know, bent over with their, uh, the heroin knot, you know, as they, as they sort of stagger forward and they lift and they get bent over.
Like, like the weight is pressing down on the back and then they stagger forward a few steps.
Look, that's a fate worse than death.
Right.
Like I don't, I don't, I know a lot of people do.
I don't judge those people.
They're above for the grace of God.
I don't have the heroin thing.
Like I have, I have more than my share of painkillers, you know, in my, and it doesn't do anything for me.
I just don't have it.
Right.
I have other problems.
Like, you know, I, I, I would be afraid of smoking weed regularly because I used to have a problem with that a long time ago and drinking.
I've had my problems.
So it's not like I'm a perfect person or I'm free from any addictive tendencies, but I just don't have the heroin thing.
Thank God.
Yeah.
So I'm not, I feel terrible for those people, but it is, that's exactly what it was.
Like that description of people who have lost their soul.
I mean, maybe, maybe they haven't hope they haven't, but it's like that.
Right.
With that, with that weight and just hollow people in the center of the hollow cities.
You know, I know that prophecy is a hundred years old.
Right.
If you believe, if you believe the Hopi people, right.
That's thousands of years old, but we know it's a hundred years old.
And it certainly wasn't anything like what existed a hundred years ago.
The cities here weren't great, but they, they weren't filled with people on fentanyl.
Right.
So it was just, just a weird thing for people to see.
And, um, as we've talked about in other spaces, uh, eschatology prophecies and predictions.
Cause I, I spent a couple of years at one point studying comparative amateur study of comparative eschatology.
So instead of just focusing on the book of revelations in the Bible, you know, I looked into, you know, what the Hopis believe, what the Buddhists believe, what are the, the different native American tribes.
Not just the Hopis, the Iroquois, you know, they had their own eschatology.
Right.
And, um, the Aztecs have eschatology right in the Mayans, as we know, and indigenous peoples.
And, you know, so I, I went around in, in my mind, I went around the world, right.
And studied those, the different eschatology.
And I have long been convinced that, that they're remote viewing.
Right.
Like I, I believe it.
And I, I believe that Christian prophets are remote viewers as well.
It doesn't mean I don't believe this difference, but I believe the ability is remote viewing.
Right.
Um, and that clairvoyance is, um, is a universal ability culturally that some people excel at.
And that's where we get these eschatological overlays.
Cause there, there are overlays between the eschatology of all people.
Um, I really notable ones, but I think that's the case with the Hopi prophecy.
So whether it was a hundred years ago or whether it was thousands of years ago, right.
Um, those are a collective shamanistic visions and they're, they're absolutely coming to pass right now.
Like, I mean, I don't know how you could not look at the weird squirrels and shit that I see on X every day.
Right.
And the strange fashion and, and, and not think of that prophecy or the, you see the fentanyl people with the fentanyl, you know, staggering through the heart of the cities and not think of that prophecy.
Uh, you know, I, I just, I think it's happening.
Um, that is definitely along the lines of, of, of, uh, Saturn and conjunct Neptune.
Um, I think that that prophecy is going to play out.
I, I imagine, I think as everyone knows, I was, I was strongly of the opinion that 3i Atlas could be that, um, could be that, uh, I was less concerned about whether there were aliens on it, in it, around it, behind it.
Like that was other people's concern.
I found it interesting and I noted it and I talked about it, but I always said, like, to me, the eschatological significance is more important.
Like, is that one of these end times, uh, signs in the heavens?
Like, is that one of these, um, stars that they talk about?
You know, the red star Kachina, the blue star Kachina and the, the comments and stars are found throughout that eschatology.
It doesn't seem like it was, but I don't know.
Right.
I still, I mean, we're pretty close to that time period.
So let's see, but it wouldn't surprise me if another one pops up in the sky in the near future.
And I tell you, um,
Although I think what's relevant as well is the, the absolute kind of the alarm and attention that was given to it, um, is just as relevant as the actual physical thing itself.
Uh, it's the fact that out of nowhere, everyone just focused on this that, well, in certain communities focused on this thing.
And, you know, the remote viewing data that was coming out early on was really alarming.
And of course that got everyone's imagination going.
And then it, then the normies got hold of it.
And even the normies were talking about it outside of X and it was an obsession.
And now it's passed and now it's gone again.
So it's almost as if there was some kind of pull on the attention of people for that.
Period.
It wasn't about the comment itself.
It was about the attention.
Right.
Okay.
And the people.
So this is interesting.
So, um, if, if someone is devoutly Christian, they can dismiss this immediately.
I am not, um, I'm not making a value judgment on, I'm looking, not looking from a religious perspective.
I'm just looking at it from the clairvoyant perspective.
Uh, I am not a fan of Alice Bailey and Theosophy and the, and the Lucent or, um, Lucent Foundation and, you know, all of that, um, Theosophy, which is the clairvoyant movement that translated esoteric Buddhist texts and brought it to the West in the late 1800s and early 1900s.
They had this, um, they developed over the time, this sort of pro Luciferian idea.
And, you know, as they all develop, whenever anyone, a movement gets involved in that, they start reframing and saying, Oh, it's not the traditional Christian view of Lucifer.
It's something else.
And I don't trust that.
Like, you know, call me a, call me a stick in the mud, but, uh, I shut down as soon as I hear that.
Um, that having been said, when you get into the, the substance of the clairvoyant visions, it comes down to, is it accurate or is it not?
Right.
And Alice Bailey, uh, predicted an interstellar comet flying through our solar system in 2025.
And she did it a hundred years earlier.
Um, well, close to a hundred years, maybe 85 years earlier.
And her, um, explanation for it was that it is, um, the, the object itself was a, a Hindu avatar on the ethereal or astral plane that would be visible to us as a, as a comet.
And that as he passed through this system, he would broadcast what she called his word, but basically that there would be some sort of broadcast.
Um, and that would change human society.
Now, I don't know if there's been a change to human society.
I guess I'm too deeply enmeshed into it to make that judgment right now.
Now, and I, I'm always very skeptical about people saying things are changing for the better, or that there's like, I'm telling you, there will be a spiritual awakening.
But up until this point in my life, whenever people talk about a spiritual or religious awakening in this country or the world, I am highly skeptical of that.
Cause I've seen the exact opposite my entire life.
So I don't know, but what I did find interesting is as the narrative around 3i Atlas changed, as it passed through the solar system, the narrative, as it got closer to planet earth evolved into one of it transmitting some sort of signal.
And that began with the speculation that it was the original, um, or it was the originator of the wow single signal in the 1970s.
So at some point, Avi low and a couple other people came out and said, this is coming from the exact point where we got that radio signal in 1970s called the wow signal.
And what if it came from this comment?
And then people started to speculate.
And there was talking about like pulsing lights.
They were talking about radio waves.
And the thing about that is right.
None of us have any idea where that's true.
It doesn't matter who puts it out, whether the government put it out, whether another government put it out, whether, uh, the guy from Harvard put it out.
Like, unless you can see it, touch it, hold it in your hand in 2026, you have no idea whether it's real or false.
You have to use your own inner spiritual discernment, right?
I don't know if there was any truth to it, but I thought it was fascinating that she had made that prediction almost a hundred years before.
And that was the substance of the discussion for a period of time was that there was a signal of some sort coming from this object.
Certainly whatever she anticipated when, cause I have read, um, some of it, and some of it's deeply insightful.
I think she was a very talented clairvoyant and, um, she, like all clairvoyants who looked into it, uh, definitely saw the reality overlay and the simulation and all that stuff.
Uh, it's very heavily encoded in esoteric language and buried in giant piles of, um, information that probably is irrelevant, but it is absolutely there.
Um, I, I actually, I have, I have a link to it at some point, but I found it like it's, it's clearly there.
And then someone else gave me a tip where it was.
Um, yeah, I, I, I, what she predicted would happen after this object flew through the solar system.
I don't support that.
I don't think that's what's going to happen.
Like she was heavy into like, well, okay.
So it is happening to a sense, right?
She was heavy into like the externalization of the hierarchy, the return of the gods.
Now, I think there are those among us who would say that we are experiencing that.
It's just that her perspective would be, that was a positive thing.
People in the, um, people in the UFO X and the ufology community would be sort of divided.
Right.
Like, so when you think of Chris Bledsoe, which Fringe is here, hello, Fringe.
When you think of Chris Bledsoe, um, you know, he is basically talking about the externalization of the hierarchy, the return of these beings.
So that's something that theosophy was talking about a hundred years ago or, or, or earlier, um, for this exact period of time, there may be a connection.
He may be connected to theosophy in some way.
I don't know.
I wouldn't be surprised.
Um, I think that a return of the conscious awareness of the archons, their role and existence is absolutely happening.
We talk about it more and we talk about it seriously and we debate it.
We debate whether it's a deception, whether it's a reality, when it began, what it means, who they are.
Uh, so this is an active debate in a community of thousands of people.
It's probably an active debate in the community of tens of thousands of people, right?
Because as I've been informed, there are other people talking about these subjects, not from the same perspective.
I'm talking about them, not from the same perspective as the intuitive underground work, but there clearly are other people who are talking about this, right?
It's not just us.
So like, this is a conversation.
This is percolating up into people's conscious minds right now.
So in that sense, it is happening.
Her sense that like, basically, I think what she would have predicted was that the archons would make contact with us.
Like the lady making contact with Chris Bledsoe, that it would become an official thing, something that everyone knew about, and that they would be basically the nightmare of every UFO ex-conspiracy theorist, that they would be dictating our government.
And maybe it will happen, I don't know, maybe it is happening, right?
But I think that that's what Alice Bailey and the theosophists saw at the end of their time was that a future world where the NHI was in charge, not from behind the scenes, but, you know, the same way they were hypothetically in charge in ancient Roman times or ancient Greek times, etc.
I don't think that's going to happen.
I could be wrong.
And life has been such a clusterfuck up until now, that it would not, it would not be super shocking to me, but I, my faith still tells me, and I wasn't born into faith.
I found it, and I'm not going to give everyone like a lecture on faith, I'm not going to evangelize people.
I'm saying that the reason it factors into my assessment is because it did not come naturally to me.
I came from a family that were, you know, agnostics, functionally atheist individuals.
I was raised to be very skeptical of and hostile towards religion in general and Christianity specifically.
And, um, there is, uh, you experience when you, we have a conversion experience, you experience a power, you experience a spiritual experience.
Um, if not, sometimes a spiritual awakening for some, but for some of us, it is a spiritual experience.
And when you recognize that it's hard to square the, what I would consider to be a pessimistic view of the future with that experience, right?
It's hard to say, like, that experience I had was incorrect.
That was wrong.
I was deceived.
And in fact, you know, we're going to have these NHI, you know, dictating some sort of crazy blood sacrifice call to some lunacy like that.
But if it happens, man, I, you know, it won't be the, it won't be the most shocking thing that's ever happened to me.
Cause things, things tend not to turn out that great.
Right.
On this planet.
Well, let's just hope, you know, I, I think that we're in the revelations period.
So I think that, you know, we're going to know one way or the other, but I, I still hold out.
And I still, my face still tells me that it's not going to turn out that way.
We'll see.
My intellect tells me maybe, but my faith tells me strongly that it won't.
Anyways, that was a digression.
I'm just saying that this was, it's amazing that we were living in times right now where people made these predictions.
Clairvoyance made these predictions hundreds of years ago, right?
Rudolf Steiner made accurate predictions a hundred years ago, more than a hundred years ago about our time.
Alice Bailey made those predictions.
Esoteric Christians made those predictions.
I would argue Gnostics and non Gnostic Christian, Christian prophets, Jewish prophets made those predictions accurately.
Like we're living in that time right now.
Those events are happening right now.
And I think that does tie into Neptune conjunct Saturn.
That is Neptune represents all kinds of things.
Aside from things we've talked about, right?
It represents communism.
Okay.
That's a weird thing.
It represents religion.
All right.
It represents spirituality.
It represents anything that's vague and idealistic.
And that comes from someplace transcendent, whether we agree with that thing or not, right?
Whether it's something that we, we particularly value or we're hostile towards or we're, or we're prone to.
If it, if it's comes from that sort of delusion, illusionary collective unconscious, like that's governed by Neptune.
And Saturn brings that into reality and gives it limitations and allows it to limit us.
And so that, that, that is occurring like right now, right?
We live in those times.
There's no question that we live in the times that people were talking about specifically like right now.
Um, whether it ends up the way people predicted, I can't say that.
I can just say that that's, this is what they were seeing.
I, I, I 100% convinced of that based on a lifetime of study.
Okay.
So I'm, I'm done with my, uh, rambling.
Um, you guys got anything else?
Lou, you got anything Bigfoot?
I don't mean to restrict.
I know, I know I go off on, on tangents.
I got to go in about five minutes.
Um, cause I have another thing set up.
Um, a non X related obligation.
Uh, but I want to, if anyone else would like to talk, but also they'd like to come up.
Hey, this is great.
Everyone has shown up.
I, I started today thinking that this was the first space that I ever held that no one
was going to show up.
Um, and then my buddy Ryan showed up and he talked for awhile and we've just been building
up an audience.
I usually run these spaces at seven and I ran it at five today.
So in a sense it's, it's my mistake.
And I also, even though I said I was going to run it, I ran unexpectedly.
I ran up against like a very popular UFO X host in his space.
Um, again, like, you know, I, I told him I was going to run one now, but who am I?
Right.
Um, are you planning any more spaces soon?
Yeah.
Saturday night, seven o'clock, the reality hack, dude.
Um, what is the technique that, um, what is the actual technique that a person, a small
person, um, uh, a person who maybe is in a weak or disadvantaged position, um, or, uh,
community, uh, can use to, um, potentially alter the world without in treating the archons.
Right.
So no magic, no, no, I don't believe that clairvoyance is, um, is related to in treating the archon.
Some people do.
Right.
But it's not related to clairvoyance.
It's not related in any way to in treating the archons.
It's based on perhaps the algorithmic principles of reality overlay.
It may be based on exploiting the principles of how this world that we're in works, but it's
not based on making bargains or deals or anything like that.
And it's the, the fundamental principle behind the modern concept concept of strategic
nonviolence.
And, um, it was a, it was an ancient concept as well.
It, you know, it was a, it was a heavily drawn from ancient Christianity, but it also
comes from Chinese culture from Taoism and, um, what they call it.
Way woo.
Oh, we'll wait.
Excuse me.
We'll wait.
Uh, but those names don't really fit the modern audience.
So I have renamed the whole thing, the whole package, the reality hack.
Cause I think, you know, while I'm still like behind the trend, right?
Like hack might be a thing that was like in vogue to say 10 years ago.
And now it's like a lame old guy thing.
But for me, it's super trendy.
Right.
So that's the audience that I'm looking at.
I think reality hack is the best way to package the idea.
Um, but if anyone else has a better idea, like I'm definitely open to it.
Definitely.
If I say strategic nonviolence and way, we'll, you know, we'll wait.
No one's going to show up.
Go ahead.
Look.
Hey, do you think you could, um, cover at some point?
Maybe Saturday might be a good idea.
Actually.
I've just discovered this concept called the monad and how it's the Achilles, the
Achilles heel of the archons.
Now, I don't know if you know anything about the monad.
I'm very vague on it myself.
I've just been looking into it.
And suddenly the algorithm on YouTube kept throwing it at me.
This not kind of thing.
I don't think the monad is the Achilles heel of the archons, but yeah, I mean, I guess
we can discuss that.
Sure.
Um, I mean, it was probably some kind of, um, you know, some kind of, okay.
So on YouTube, look, I am not saying how to defeat the archons.
That's basically the angle I was saying.
Okay.
So we can talk more about how to defeat the archons.
Um, maybe some of it on Saturday.
I'm going to do it Thursday and Saturdays, right?
So we can talk more about that next Thursday and I'll, I think I'm going to be adjusting
my other obligation.
So perhaps I can run them at seven o'clock.
Like everyone is comfortable with and I'm comfortable with.
Right.
Um, we can definitely talk more about that.
Like in updates, because there are constant updates to this.
Now, um, I get new information all the time.
Um, as far as, uh, yeah, I, I think that, um, the, the problem.
So that stuff all started to pop up when we went on to do room.
I'm not saying we caused it.
Okay.
Correlation does not equal causality.
I'm just stating that there was an exponential explosion of computer generated of first influencers,
both in the UFO fields and influences, the real influencers, big, big counts in the UFO fields,
in the, um, AI related field, like the, the people who talk to their AIs and come up with
all kinds of crazy stuff.
And in the, um, magosphere, strangely, uh, right around when we, um, when we started talking
to publicly started talking and sharing videos and posts with, um, with fringe and doomer.
So maybe there's a relationship.
Maybe we were riding the wave, right?
Maybe we were just, we were just on trend at that point.
But since then, there's been this, this exponential increase in videos on YouTube about, uh, our cons.
And the caution that I have about that is that I think that more than likely those videos are an
attempt to, to muddy the waters.
I do watch some of them myself.
Some of them are okay.
Some of them are like, you know, what you do is you throw a lot of truth in and you throw
a couple of falsehoods and that sort of muddies things.
I'm not saying that they're all like, I'm not saying there's like an office of some place
where the people are like, we have to stop.
We have to stop people from talking about, you know, the archons in X spaces.
So let's generate 50,000 YouTube videos.
No, I mean, I think that people just do it to get views.
Like it's, they're trying to stay on trend and other people might try to be helpful, but they
don't quite know what they're talking about entirely.
So yeah, we can do more about the, the archons and updates, um, going forward.
You know, I'll try to come up with a way to fit that all together in next Thursday.
And if it, if it comes up on Saturday, we can, we can do that.
Saturday is more about like, um, how to adapt the principles that, uh, individuals have used
to change the world, to changing your life.
Right.
And how to, how to do that without getting involved in manifesting without getting involved
in, I'm not trying to tell people what to do or live their lives.
I'm not making judgments about people's decisions.
What I'm saying is that, you know, I believe that there's a, there's a cost for, for making
deals with non-human intelligence to better one's life.
Um, the people who do that, they, they justify it by saying, no, no, no.
They justify it by saying non-human intelligence isn't real.
It's just an aspect of our own unconscious mind.
Okay.
So they convinced themselves.
They're not talking to anything that doesn't exist independently, that the things that they're
calling with their rituals are actually themselves.
They're their own God.
And, uh, they're just kind of, I don't know why they would need to go through this elaborate
thing with candles and whatever, but okay.
Okay.
That's, that's their philosophy.
If they're actually talking to non-human intelligence, then they're making deals and they're making
deals with their own jailers.
It's just not, it's just not what I behavior that I would support.
I don't, I think it will bite you in the ass.
I think it will, um, it will lead to a significant karmic burden for the individual involved.
Let's just say that.
Would you, um, would you put chaos magic into that category as well?
I think it's less than that.
I think it's, it's, it's, it's, it's less than that category.
Chaos magic sort of overlaps anything we might do to improve our lives.
Um, but you know what?
It's a gateway.
So, you know, like I say, smoking weed is a gateway drug, right?
Like you start off doing simple things with chaos magic.
And then that kind of draws you into formally entreating our cons and non-human intelligence.
Um, it's a person's own decision to make.
Like a lot of people get involved in that.
They end up, they end up accruing a debt, um, in my opinion, and just based on observing their lives.
Um, but there's, I mean, look, uh, Grant Morrison, right?
Uh, comic book artist, Grant Morrison, uh, was the individual who first came up with the concept of the hyper sigil of using, um, a creative effort, like writing a book or a movie or a play or a comic.
Um, as a, as a, as a form of moving sigil to change one's life.
So as a, as the highest, um, or most advanced form of chaos magic, right?
Um, I think that that is something that we all experience when we watch movies.
So we're all immersed in people's hyper sigils all the time.
You know, we, it's tough because there are a lot of people who want to cast a, a broad judgment against everything occult.
And maybe at some point we could have done that, but in order to do that in our time, we have to be in denial of how, how deeply penetrated our lives are by the occult.
Right?
Like, so we're, we're all looking at scrying screens right now, whether we, whether we admit that to ourselves or not.
Um, if we went back 500 years and, you know, gave Nostradamus or some medieval magician, the cell phone in our hands or the computer screen.
Right?
They would look at it as a scrying screen.
I'm sure you guys have seen, everyone laughs at this, which, which means that something, right?
When you're, if you're taking flack, you're over the target.
The correlation between ancient sigils from the middle ages, Solomonic seals and computer circuits, because there is, there is a, a, a obvious correlation between the two, but people will just laugh it off.
Uh, we live in a time where we're, and this is something that like you would expect if you would studied, um, Anthosafi and the work of Rudolf Steiner and other clairvoyants, uh, up until about a hundred years ago.
Like there would, that our time is a time when the occult deeply interpenetrates our lives.
Um, so if, even if we judge, um, occultism and others, there are very few of us, probably no one.
It's no offense to anyone here, but probably no one in this room, uh, just by the virtue of being here and being on X, who isn't, um, isn't connected to the occult in some way.
Right. So you just want, if you want to navigate through life in our time, you just want to avoid anything that relates to in treating non-human entities for personal advantage or changes in your life.
Um, what I'm saying is there is another way to do it, right?
There is a, there is a way to change life, to make changes in a person's circumstance by studying, you know, the dynamics of our environment and other human beings and utilizing them.
Right. These are the principles utilized in strategic non-violence all the time, and they can be adapted on a personal level as a reality hack.
Um, it's not the, it's not the same type of magical thinking. You can't just write something on a piece of paper and forget about it and then hope it into existence.
Right. A lot of that is confirmation bias.
Anyhow. Right. A lot of that is half the time you're hoping for things.
You know, if, if a young, attractive person is trying to manifest a partner in their life and then a partner enters their life and they say, Oh my God, that manifestation works.
I, I was, I was alone. And now I'm with a young, attractive person.
Well, you know, if you leave a young, attractive person alone long enough, it's, it's almost impossible for them not to end up in a relationship with another young, attractive person. Right.
And whether they manifest or not. So that's just one example of how confirmation bias plays into that.
I'm not telling you not to chaos magic, chaos magic, do what, do what you're going to do.
I'm just saying, be careful, you know, try not to entreat the archons to make deals with them, because if you're making a deal with your captor, you're not a captive anymore.
Right. You're a willing participant. You're saying, look, this place sucks and I'm not here voluntarily, but I would be here voluntarily if I had a boat.
And, um, you know, if I had a hot wife, you know, give me three million. I don't even want to say this out loud. I didn't want to say it as a just because that's how serious, um, in treating them can, can be.
You don't want to, uh, you know, setting goals is one thing, but there's like a line someplace between goal setting and being willing to accept favors from non-human intelligence.
Um, and I just, I just don't think you want to get involved in that. Right. You can't, you can't stand blamelessly. If you're trying to get out of here, uh, and you're sitting in front of them and they say, well, you know, dude, we gave you a boat. You wanted a boat. We gave you a boat. You want to be here. Right.
So that's, I don't know that that was me repeating myself three times because I'm tired and it's time for me to go. Um, I got to pack it in. I didn't sleep last night and I got a thing in 10 minutes and I'm going to be woefully unprepared.
Uh, but I'm super excited that both of you guys came up to talk. I hope you're going to come up in future spaces. I, I get caught. Like I know I can go on for hours, but you know, steering at a bunch of like icons of people without any, without any feedback. It's a, it's a psych out.
Yeah. I'm a fairly confident person, but I'm not that confident. Um, you're good at it though. You are really good at it. I appreciate it. I don't know anyone else can do it quite like you to be honest. Well, no, I really appreciate that.
Thank you. But I still be my internal experience is a lot better when I have people who will, you know, talk to me a little bit. Um, I can still go on, but you know, at least I've got that direct feedback. Right. Like I, I don't have to wonder, you know, I don't have to get involved in catastrophic thinking. Like, you know, what if I'm really sucking? Right. It's like being a comedian up on stage and you're not getting any applause from the audience. You just start to assume. Maybe they don't hate you, but you just start to assume that they do. Right.
Um, yeah, but Bigfoot, uh, it's great to hear from you. Lou, it's great to hear from you and everyone I should stop and say, you know, um, uh, West Virginia. That's great to see you. Thank you. Sarah. Thank you. Sinan. Kiki. I haven't seen you in a while. Thank you.
Andrew, it's great to see you. Um, I'm sorry, Par. I should remember the other part of your name, but I don't want to click on it right now and screw up my screen because I'm, I'm not good with technology. Jake. It's great to see you. Sadie. It's always great to see you. I'm glad you're back. And I love your expos every day that they're great. Melissa. You're my, you're always here. Um,
I really appreciate it. Uh, John, it's good to see. I haven't seen you in a long time. I've seen you in other spaces, but it's great to have you back here. Um, yeah. And come up and speak. And, um, on, on Saturday, on Thursday, guys, uh, or not, it's up to you. Does anyone have anything else before I go? Because as you can see, I'm like, I'm crashing.
All right. Um, I'm going to, uh, in the space is going to be 15 seconds of silence for some of us. And for others, it will happen immediately. I, I, again, thank you very much for coming. I thought tonight I wasn't going to have anyone. And so this is a great turnout for me. And, uh, I, I look forward to coming back on Saturday, uh, to talk about the reality act at 7 PM.
Thank you.